I know that what I'm about to ask you to
do is sort of difficult to do because
it's exploding in our faces every single
day but imagine just for a second if you
can and this will be easy for some
people in our audience that there were
no Russia story right imagine that there
were no investigations into Donald Trump
no indictment no attempt to obstruct the
investigation by firing all sorts of
people put the entire thing aside for a
moment which again I think a lot of
people in our audience will actually not
have trouble doing but some of you will
we've now learned about a completely
separate Trump campaign scandal which
has exploded in the last 24 hours
because of a really really good
investigation published by Britain's
channel 4 and the company in question
here is Cambridge analytic that's not
Cambridge Massachusetts right near our
studio but that's Cambridge UK and they
also play a role in today's major
breaking story about Facebook which
we'll get to later on in the program
Cambridge analytic ëcause themselves of
big data behavioural micro targeting
political campaign support firm at least
that's what they call themselves on
Twitter and what they do it turns out is
a combination of opposition research and
social media targeting along with we
have now learned blackmail scams bribes
the hiring of prostitutes to set up
honey traps as well as perpetuating fake
news the channel 4 documentary which you
should absolutely watch first part is
out about 20 minutes I believe a second
part is upcoming the documentary exposes
their techniques and it goes all the way
up to the top and when I say all the way
up to the top I don't mean close to the
top or near the top I mean to the
absolute top and what channel 4 did is
create an undercover investigation where
they had a an individual posing as a sri
lankan who was working with a family in
Sri Lanka and the family had aspirations
for political office in Sri Lanka and
what they wanted to meet with Cambridge
analytic to do was to sort of interview
Cambridge general
to see if we want to run if our family
member wants to run for elected office
in Sri Lanka could you help us
what would you be able to do in order to
help us and after just a couple of
initial meetings the fake possible
client which was really an undercover
investigator working with channel 4 ends
up meeting with none other than the head
of Cambridge analytic Alexander Nicks
and Alexander Nicks is a guy who is a
public figure he has spoken at
conferences all around the world about
just the amazing and great things that
Cambridge analytic a does and he gets
caught on hidden camera in this channel
for investigation talking about how his
firm has lots of experience bringing in
prostitutes to set up politicians he
specifically suggests the idea of
Ukrainian prostitutes as a possible as
possible agents of help with this Sri
Lankan campaign he talks about what
Cambridge analytic AHA's done how they
are experts in this stuff his
co-conspirator in the image were showing
our television audience now sitting to
Nyx's right talking about how they are
masters of disguise in doing this type
of thing and this is yet another story
that connects directly to the Oval
Office and to Jared Kushner and to
Steven Bannon who at one point was a
part owner of Cambridge analytic a stake
holder in Cambridge analytic ah this
company was Donald Trump's campaign
consultants for 2016 and this raises a
whole new and separate specter of
suspicion on Donald Trump's campaign so
now if you want you can totally
disregard the Russia story not that it's
going away I just mean if you're
thinking about how Trump won you can
temporarily put aside all of the Russia
stuff and now we have to explore whether
Donald Trump won at least in part
because of the actions of a firm that
uses prostitutes and blackmail and
entrapment and bribe so here's how this
is going to go it's already happening to
some degree Cambridge analytic I will
deny using these tactics in their work
for Trump
they'll also deny it more broadly
I'll get to that in a second Trump and
his team will say listen we did some
work with Cambridge analytic it was very
minor it was just social media targeting
and that's it we will all be incredibly
skeptical and hopefully investigative
journalists will start digging into the
detail about exactly which tactics
Cambridge analytic I did use to help
Donald Trump in his 2016 campaign and it
might come out that yeah
Cambridge analytic I merely did some
Facebook targeting for Trump with some
of that data that they got from Facebook
which we'll talk about later today it
might come out that Cambridge analytic
Adhan 'old Trump but what is without
question is that this is one of the
biggest corporate embarrassments in a
long time and it's clear that Cambridge
analytic is clueless about how to
respond to this because their top people
are on video admitting to this stuff
watch the 19 or 20 minute documentary
and you will see Alexander Knicks and
Turnbull mark Turnbull or I forget his
first name Turnbull who is the the
co-partner there the other partner
talking about all the things they have
done and can do and would suggest doing
so let's now go through some of the
responses and defenses from Cambridge
analytic ah which are just the best I'm
relishing truly seeing this stuff first
this one's sort of minor the official
Twitter account for Cambridge analytic
sent out a tweet about the Channel 4
documentary where they said tonight's
Channel 4 News story gives a highly
misleading picture of the company and
what we do yeah it's misleading because
not only do they hire prostitutes for
honey traps and create blackmail videos
they'll also give you advice about how
to run Google ads so yeah that wasn't
really made a big part of the Channel 4
investigation should have been included
in the interest of full disclosure next
Cambridge analytic a floats the idea
that it was all a joke about hiring
prostitutes that the mention of the
hiring prostitutes was a way to figure
out whether their potential Sri Lankan
client had bad intentions they were
trying to see is the Sri Lankan client
immoral because we would never do any of
this stuff we were trying to suss it out
here's a quote from the
statement that Cambridge analytic about
that this is just have the barf bags
nearby please they said despite this
clear statement the undercover reporter
later attempted to entrap it's all
projection Cambridge analytic and traps
and now they're saying someone else
tried to entrap them attempted to entrap
Cambridge analytical executives by
initiating a conversation about
unethical practices after several
meetings discussing ostensibly
legitimate projects the reporter
unexpectedly and suddenly turned the
conversation towards practices such as
corruption and the entrapment of
political figures assessing the legality
and reputational risks associated with
new projects is critical for us and we
routinely undertake conversations with
prospective clients to try to tease out
any unethical or illegal intentions that
is just the best and then they go on to
say the to Cambridge analytic executives
at the meeting humored these questions
and actively encourage the prospective
client to disclose his intentions it's
just a lie I mean if you watch the 20
minute documentary you will see that the
questions from the undercover reporter
are so general like can you tell me
about the type of opposition research
that you do and the CA people the
Cambridge analytical people volunteer
there's opposition research but there's
more than opposition research they
volunteer all of the stuff and the idea
that they were merely trying to suss out
and were humoring and testing out the
undercover reporter is ridiculous and
case in point within just a few meetings
they bring along their top guy alexander
nix the head of the company cambridge
analytical reportedly has according to
crunch base between 100 and 250
employees when they suspect the client
of may be pulling their leg or having
bad intentions they send in their CEO
the top guy to meet directly with this
person who on earth would believe this
explanation and the bigger concern is
not mean listen these people are
horrible right this is this is not
democracy this is a perversion
of the democratic system and the big
picture here is that it connects
directly to Trump and right-wing media
is ignoring that connection it connects
to Steven Bannon because he held a stake
he was part owner in Cambridge analytic
until he started working for the Trump
Organization a trumpet campaign Trump
administration and sold his stake in cà
although very very late and according to
reports it also appears that it was
Jared Kushner who wanted to hire this
firm in the first place and it just so
happens that Kushner's family has a
history of entrapping people with sex
Jared Krishna's father Charles Kushner
hired a prostitute to sleep with his
sister's husband and then used it as
leverage against him and it just so
happens that Jared Kushner wants to hire
a company that we now know engages in
similar practices this is a whole new
scandal right it is a whole new scandal
in the Trump administration right-wing
media is going way out of its way to
keep this out of the headlines check
this out from this morning I just said
let's just see what's going on in
different right-wing news websites
Drudge Report you go there Jared and the
prince
you see stories about just about
everything other than this major major
story go to Fox news.com
what do you see another blast rocks
Texas not that that's not a story we're
gonna be talking about that story
tomorrow and all sorts of other stuff
but not this you go to Ben Shapiro's
right-wing news website daily wire
package which shrapnel explodes at Texas
FedEx facility will Germany block Israel
from finally getting a seat on the UN
progressive groups looking to organize
march in support of louis farrakhan
palestinian terrorist murder three young
jews abbas silent but nothing about this
major major story and I could go on with
other examples it's like it just doesn't
exist and this is ultimately the problem
because of the filter bubbles and the
echo chambers and the algorithms tons of
people will never hear about this or by
the time they do they'll inherently
assume if I haven't heard about this
until now it must not really be a big
story that is one of the biggest
problems here that this putting aside
everything else that's going on in
connection
the Trump administration right now this
is a major new scandal and so many
people will never hear about it and if
they do it'll be half-baked harebrained
attempt to debunk the entire story but
there's no debunking and the flaccid
attempts from Cambridge analytical to
say oh it's all misleading and we were
just testing them if we were just joking
about all the stuff its BS and I hope
somehow it gets through to the committed
trumpets although quite frankly I'm not
super optimistic about that send me your
thoughts about this story or any other
from today I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership